[Music]
all right
the ftts conference is insightful
amazing good business networking it's a
place to be mandatory for a brighter
future
it is my great pleasure to officially
open our ftth conference 2023
main objective is that every citizen
every business should be connected with
a very high-speed connection possibly
with five
we recognize that there is still much to
be done to ensure that all communities
have access to this vital technology
in order to be here to represent Ukraine
if you your company or your partners
think about how to make this world
better
you have the biggest opportunity to take
one Village in Ukraine and fulfill your
bravest Minds about reconstruction
[Applause]
ensuring high quality internet access
for everyone will be absolutely
essential if we are to capture the full
benefits of the digital transformation
so it's great progress how are we still
in our Force 2.7 billion people I'm
connected
[Music]
thank you
foreign
looking forward to seeing you all in
2024 in Berlin